this video is sponsored by movie i'm
reliving
the same day over and over
groundhog day today in the greek myth of
sisyphus
sisyphus is granted immortality but he
must spend eternity rolling a stone up a
hill
a difficult and thankless task and every
time he reaches the top the stone comes
rolling back down
unable to die sisyphus is destined to a
life of laboring
without any hope of escape or measure of
progress
if we strip away the future with its
consequences for our actions
don't you worry about cholesterol lung
cancer love handles
i don't worry about anything anymore
leaving us with only our own existence
and how
we live each day can we find meaning
in life existential philosopher albert
camus saw that as the absurd plight of
humanity
stuck toiling in a godless meaningless
universe
or labor ultimately amounting to nothing
in his essay the myth of sisyphus camus
uses the greek legend as a metaphor for
our lives
so does groundhog day what would you do
if you were stuck in one place and every
day was exactly the same
and nothing that you did mattered
[Music]
no that sums it up for me and so does
the 2020 andy samberg rom-com
palm springs good day so far today
tomorrow yesterday it's all the same
it's a metaphor that might feel
especially appropriate right now when
many of us have been stuck at home on
our own for
days or weeks i don't know my sense of
time is a little fuzzy living days that
might feel more mundane and repetitive
[Laughter]
watch out for that first step it's a
doozy
in groundhog day phil connors plays a
sort of cosmic game
stuck reliving the same day in a town he
hates surrounded by people he hates
he despises everything around him upon
realizing his new fate what the hell
he moves from the pursuit of hedonism to
suicidal despair
toast to apathetically accepting his
fate i wake up
every day right here right in
punxsutawney
and it's always february 2nd and there's
nothing i can do about it
and finally to personal transformation
and finding meaning in virtuous selfless
living
by the end of the film he is freed from
his prison but he opts largely
to continue living in the world he's
been trapped in let's live here
a changed man the town and people around
him now look
completely different it's one of those
infinite time lip situations you might
heard about
that i might have heard about yeah it's
into this world that
not only contains groundhog day but it's
countless offspring that palm springs
arrives
palm springs acknowledges its
predecessor maybe it's a karma thing
what is yeah what if it's like
to get out of this you have to be
selfless and then you're free
oh my god what if life just keeps going
for everyone else here but not you and
me until we've earned our way out but
it has little interest in rehashing the
same ground
instead it seeks to find something new
and interesting in the concept by making
some critical changes
palm springs brings other people into
the loop guess you followed me
but this changes surprisingly little
about the philosophical implications of
the time loop world with other people
there you can measure your internal
change against those people
you got here that's all that matters but
if you really want to know someone
deeper
it does matter but still without a
future what does that change
even mean i'm not gonna see my kids grow
up
never gonna walk a little livvy down the
aisle by bringing other people into the
loop palm springs
strengthens the concept as a metaphor
for our own lives
becomes not just about an individual's
isolated search for meaning but a
community search for meaning
in the face of a seemingly absurd world
it doesn't matter that everything resets
and people don't remember we remember we
have to deal with the things that we do
oh my god crimea river
and just like people in real life take
different approaches to finding meaning
so do the characters stuck in the loop
in palm springs
the universe henceforth without a master
seems to him neither sterile nor futile
the struggle itself towards the heights
is enough to fill a man's heart
one must imagine sisyphus happy for
camus
we must embrace the absurdity of life
wait
stop there's a bomb in the cake
don't worry i used to be a bomb guy
everyone stand back
camus says if we accept its
meaninglessness and live passionately
we can find happiness in palm springs
this is essentially what we find
niles trying to do you just have to find
peace you know in groundhog day for a
time we find phil connors living this
way
but i don't think either film ultimately
accepts camus idea
groundhog day phil eventually accepts
the absurdity of his new life
but mere acceptance isn't enough is this
what you do with eternity
phil doesn't stay stuck in his new world
he's eventually granted freedom by
whoever is running the cosmic game he's
playing it's so
beautiful but not just when he's
accepted his absurd life
his freedom comes only once he's
personally transformed
the moral of the story here is clear
virtuous
selfless living is necessary to find
true happiness
and freedom in groundhog day there is
some kind of ethical judge
which renders the universe not
meaningless and
not like our world as camus sees it i'm
a god
your god i'm a god i'm not the
god palm springs deconstructs this by
eliminating an
ethical moral basis for escape i am the
antichrist
i'm just kidding there is no god the
character's position
inside or outside of the loop isn't
dictated by karma
fate god or some kind of ethic
instead it's just part of what camus
calls the formless chaos
of the universe sarah and niles have a
choice to exit the loop
or not are you scared to leave what no
not at all i just don't want to leave
palm springs sees the world as kamusaw
without an ultimate ethical or moral
judge
but it ultimately rejects camus call not
to seek meaning
and to find happiness in accepting the
absurd
roy possibly models the closest thing to
camus suggestion
at least for now he accepts his absurd
life
this was always a good day here
you know sarah refuses to accept her new
absurd life i can't keep waking up in
here
and finds meaning in striving to
overcome her plight
that was awful and crazy it should never
have happened putting her life in order
and finding a way out
she is ready to move forward niall's
journey is a little messier
for niles like sarah accepting the
absurd isn't enough i thought i knew how
to live
i didn't or i don't
but he doesn't find his meaning in
self-development and striving to
progress
both groundhog day and palm springs end
with a couple
in a relationship groundhog day rita is
phil's object of attention early on but
phil isn't good enough for her and she
consistently rejects him
you think i'm acting like this because
i'm egocentric i know you're eco-centric
it's your defining characteristic
by the end phil has realized he doesn't
need rita
well where are you going would you like
to get a cup of coffee i'd love to can i
have a rain check i've got some errands
i've got to run
okay he's found meaning by living a
selfless life instead of making her a
goal
it's only then that she becomes truly
interested in phil
wow i think you're a bargain in palm
springs however
sarah is where niles is finding his
meaning take a look around
whatever you're after it ain't here
here i think the film is clear niles
finds his happiness
inside or outside the loop with sarah
it's really irrelevant to me as long as
i'm with you
phil connors in groundhog day sidesteps
camus for another kind of existentialist
philosophy
in the face of an absurd world where his
actions have no consequences
phil is making a kierkegaardian leap of
faith
he chooses to live virtuously without
knowing if it will ultimately result in
anything
when he does this the karmic gods of
punxsutawney let him out of the loop
seemingly affirming his leap of faith
kierkegaard would say that
phil by acting in faith that his
virtuous
actions actually mean something he's
saved from his absurd life
palm springs uses the sisyphean metaphor
as a launching point for some fun
philosophical meandering
but the answer it presents to the
questions the metaphor
brings up feel weaker to me personally
than either camus or kierkegaard's
it's all meaningless right i mean
i hope it's not all meaningless the best
it can seem to muster is a lukewarm
rejection of camus acceptance of the
absurd
cheers to pretending not to care
and an affirmation that life meaningless
or not is better spent with people you
love
i can survive just fine without you you
know
but there there's a chance that this
life can be
a little less mundane with you in it
but i think that's okay that's super low
bar that's a great place to start
while it's fun to talk about the
philosophical implications of these two
films
having a coherent philosophical
viewpoint is not what makes a good movie
and to some extent by not giving a hard
answer
palm springs reflects real life it
brings up some
questions and provides multiple
potential answers
but it's still up to you how will you
find meaning in the loop
special thank you to mubi for sponsoring
this video mubi
is an online streaming cinema with a
heavy focus on curation
they have a library of international
indian art house films that's
available worldwide and every day they
add a new film with an explanation of
why they think that film
is worth watching the film i'm going to
recommend to you today is werner
herzog's new
family romance llc the film is narrative
fiction but he shoots it almost more
like one of his documentaries it's an
interesting exploration of performance
truth and lies and i recommend you check
it out if you're a fan of herzog's work
when you get your free trial
at mubi.com thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight for your extended free
trial as always thank you so much for
watching and i want to give a special
thank you to my patrons
go to patreon.com thomasflight to learn
more about how you can support
the ongoing creation of content on my
channel